pervasive cultural message that says
commodifying yourself even to the point
of making yourself a subscription
product on only fans is not only
legitimate but it's also empowering it
leaves people in the situation where
you've got this incredibly kind of
adversarial and Incredibly hostile and
Incredibly exploitative dynamic between
the Sexes such that it's now almost
impossible to extend enough trust and
enough vulnerability I think to another
person to be willing to take the risk of
loving someone and I think that's
catastrophic over the long term for
people just being able to find happiness
or kids or anything really
tell me how do you arrive at giving a
critique of feminism why do you have any
credentials to do this
well I mean I'm I'm a woman which is a
start
um
I was a fairly rabidly fully paid up
second wave feminists in my teens and
then third wave slash woke well early
adopter of the whole kind of awoke
um post-modern world view in my 20s you
know and did My Level best to live it
I'd say until I was about 28 and then
for a whole load of very complicated
reasons kind of lost my faith in that
way of living
um and in the process of kind of
reassembling a world view which made
sense
um which I reckon took about seven years
um having having kind of hit that
quarter life crisis
um I came out the other end thinking
well I don't believe in progress anymore
and I thought well I've always thought
of myself as a feminist but if being a
if feminism is held up as one of the
kind of central planks in the in the
sort of evidence stack that says where
we're on a sort of never-ending upward
path of progress right
um and people say you know the first
thing people say when you say well you
know prove it like if you say I don't
believe in progress and they'll be like
well how can you say that you're a woman
like you know things are much better for
women now than they were before you know
that's just kind of treated as
self-evident and I thought okay well
this
um is it is it still possible to be a
feminist if you don't believe in
progress and I thought well I still care
about women's interests and I still
think those are often sidelined
um but but then that sort of started me
down a whole Rabbit Hole of
um you know the the relationship between
feminism and progress and
um
and that in the course of which I got
married I had a baby and having a baby
made me think a great deal more about
what feminism thinks considers progress
to mean
most of which seems kind of um
structurally predicated on not being a
mother or you know
being a mother put it this way like
being a mum and being emancipated in the
terms that had sort of normally set out
by what I think of as magazine feminism
you know the kind of Jezebel and of
Cosmopolitan variant
um they just don't they don't stack they
don't they don't Square very comfortably
and so I spent I spent you know
personally quite a bit of time trying to
trying to make sense of that problem
pushing a buggy around the empty daytime
streets of a small town in England
um you know it's not like your mind
stops working just because you've had a
baby
um so their aren't sort of pushing the
buggy around thinking about thinking
about secondary feminism and thinking
about being a stay-at-home mum and
thinking about how different it was
actually to the impression that I'd
always internalized of it from feminists
from the the sort of liberal feminist
Orthodoxy which says there's nothing
more in for dig basically and this is
this is you being oppressed and this is
terrible and I'm like well actually
um you know in in practice for me
um you know it's quite a nice life
um you know but the the major downsides
of being a stay at home mom are
loneliness
um and
um well it's a nice life provided the
main the main downside is loneliness and
it's quite a nice life provided you have
enough funds and provided uh you get on
with your husband you know if either of
those things is is not there you know
you've got problems and I mean that and
that led me down a whole Rabbit Hole of
looking at how we got to thinking of um
how we got to thinking of
women's
of the good for women as being something
which was just anything but that
um yeah there's a there's a quote from
Helen Roy that I keep on coming up
against which is today women especially
are sincerely frightened by the idea of
becoming just a wife and a mother
American women willingly run from the
home from the Specter of becoming a
prisoner or a parasite or even worse a
domestic prostitute into the arms of a
corporate employer laughably we call
this process Freedom right and it you
know it it remains an open question for
me absolutely Esther you know just how I
mean Wendell Berry put it really nicely
wrote a superb I say feminism the body
and the Machine where he talks about his
wife
um who doesn't have a she doesn't have a
paid employer she's his wife and he's
got to be with he's like well she's her
own boss
um and it's he he's like I struggle to
see how
um sending her off to work for an
employer who gets to tell her what to do
all day is makes her in any UK in any
way meaningfully more free than she
currently is
um and he makes the point more generally
about the transition from agrarian life
where people were kind of economically
productive within a home to and
particular you know the role of women in
a household like that where you might be
looking looking after a small holding
and raising kids and making making
processing raw materials into Goods for
the family and doing all sorts of other
subsistence work all of which is
economically productive
um and comparing that to and you know in
what in what meaningful senses is a
woman like that
um liberated by being sent to punch the
same four holes on an assembly line all
day you know it's
it's it's it's hard to it's hard to
square but I mean this is this was all
this is all what led me to to write to
writing the book which I've which
I've just finished writing feminism
against progress I spent the first third
of it looking at
setting out the rabbit hole that I went
down and setting out you know this is
the sort of deep it ended up with me
doing a sort of deep reread of the whole
history of feminism since the Industrial
Revolution which is it's a lot less dry
than it sounds because I mean it's the
history of how men and women live
together and in just normal life and you
know obviously you can't do that in
incredibly granular detail because it
varies depending on where you are and um
who you're talking to but the sort of
broad outlines of it are consistent
enough that you can make some sort of
General claims and and really it's the
story of men and women of of work
leaving the home
and that's the story of industrial
revolution is you know from from the
point of view of family life it's the
story of work leaving the home
um sure so some people have always
worked outside the home yeah I mean
soldiers obviously are not as the sub
being a soldier is not a work from home
occupation but you know in a in a how in
a economy a sort of pre-modern economy
that's mostly
um Artisan or agrarian
um work
um the the basic unit of production
isn't an individual
um you know with a sort of economic
relationship to an employer in the state
the other basic unit of production is a
household
um and actually the legal structures
which women in one which in the
industrial era were and started to find
incredibly oppressive were oppressive
because they were the the they were the
economic they were the legal structures
which were designed to accommodate a
productive household
um with and so there was there was one
single legal hit which was in the
pre-modern world the man
um who was who who had the official
title of the property and had to have
the sort of formal power
um but whether or not women were
radically disempowered in that
context in in every in every case I
think is much more Up For Debate and
it's generally treated as axiomatic that
women were just sort of effectively kind
of chattel slaves and property up into
that up to that point and I think I
think the literature doesn't really
support that you know if you look at if
you look at characters like the wife of
bath in Chaucer
um you know is writing in the in the
Middle Ages um and he has these
incredibly sort of Larger than Life
female characters and I mean yeah you
can point to things like you know like
the skulls Bridal and so on but you know
they're the sort of device that was
placed on on the the head of a woman who
was was deemed to be talking too much
um but
um there's a fair amount of evidence
from from the literature and also from
from anthropological studies of small
village life
um that makes a fairly compelling case
that you know in a lot of these settings
not all of them but in a lot of them you
know women women made women generally
don't wield formal formal power you know
they're not they're not the decision
makers and the property owners but they
wield considerable informal power in
ways which is much more difficult to put
your finger on because it doesn't come
with title deeds and so on but they but
but women in a village in a sort of you
know pre-pre-modern style Village will
will wield power by controlling access
to reputation or controlling controlling
their husbands access to information or
you know the power of gossip and the
power of public shame and there are all
sorts of very subtle
um very very subtle community-based
forms of power which I think are not are
often not accounted for in this is why
I've been so interested in female
intrasexual competition recently because
it's way more interesting than male
intersexual competition male heat in
these kind of very Brazen upfront loud
garish ways whereas the swords that
women wield is significantly more subtle
and nuanced so to go back to your
20s story to now it kind of feels a
little bit to me almost like a uh a PTSD
Rehabilitation that you needed to work
out
philosophically
morally ethically existentially what had
happened to you during that period and
then you have this whatever seven year
reflection which is capped off with
having husband child dog and then that
is a vector it's like a like a synthesis
of all of this stuff coming to the front
maybe you had some questionings
beforehand and you go what does it mean
what does it mean what does it mean and
then finally you've got this experience
what does it mean given the fact that
rights for women have changed over the
last 100 years
during the Industrial Revolution or the
last 200 years through the Industrial
Revolution does that not suggest that
there has been some sort of progress
well things change obviously
um you know I don't think it necessarily
follows I I don't think it follows from
that that everything has got better in
some sort of absolute sense you know I
think you can make you can make a very
you know it's obviously the case that
some things on some metrics life is a
lot better than it used to be
um I just don't think it's possible to
prove
um in any in any convincing way that the
absolute sum of human Felicity or virtue
or happiness or well-being or you know
any metric you care to name
um is is better now than it was a couple
of thousand years ago you know it's not
you know by the same token I don't think
it's possible to prove that it's worse
you know I'm not a declinist or one of
those the world is going to hell in a
handbasket people I just I just don't
think it's like the moment the moment
you say well well Pro we're making
progress you're like sure but you know
on what metric and the moment you've
just you've the moment you pointed a
metric you've already assumed the truth
of what you set out to prove do you see
what I mean you begged the question a
little bit yeah you've begged the
questions exactly okay
in what ways in in what ways is would
you consider or what are the main ways
in which you consider uh progress to
have been downwardly trajected for women
over the last period
um
well some things have got a lot some
things are a lot better I think I I
wouldn't frame it quite like that I
wouldn't say some things have got yeah I
mean yeah yes some things have got
better and some things have got it worse
but my argument is that
um what we think of as a story of
progress if we just if we just bracket
progress for a minute if what we think
of as a story of progress is actually
the story it's a story of Technology
above and it's about it's a story of men
and women
um responding and women and feminism is
women's particular response in aggregate
to the way the ways the Industrial
Revolution changed family life and and
women's lives in particular
um first by taking work out of the home
and second you know so for
for Bourgeois women for well for women
at the top end of the food chain and
also for women at the bottom of the food
chain in a different way
um forcing women's work out of the home
as well so it was a working-class woman
went into factories and then had to find
a way of look at figure out what to do
with their children
and women and so and women of the the
sort of clerical clerical class and and
the upper class
um suddenly he had much more comfortable
lives and wondered what to do with
themselves and so agitated for access to
um access to public life you know in
sort of knowledge work so you know
started to started to demand access to
clerical jobs and medical training and
access to universities Etc and so on so
there's and all of this is really
Downstream of the changes wrought by the
Industrial Revolution which suddenly you
know it radically reordered how Society
worked and changed to where what work
meant changed where it happened and
changed how men and women men and women
live together and what I think is really
interesting is that over the course of
really the from in England from the 18th
century and in America from the 19th
century because that was where how the
sort of tidal wave of industrialization
moved you see this intense preoccupation
with
um the the role of the Sexes and
particularly with the role of women
there's a huge amount of discourse that
happens about you know what what how men
and women should relate to one another
and how what women what what the role of
women now is and that and rightly so
because because it was everything was
suddenly different and all of the
settled Norms that had had obtained up
into up to that point just weren't there
anymore yeah so women women were
displaced from the home by things like
the washing machine
in a strange way because they were
liberated from having to do the I mean
it was hours per day right that women
would have to wash and dry clothes
typically in the past or otherwise I
mean I mean white good sweat because
it's a 20th century phenomenon and that
sort of had a that had a different set
of effects but I mean if you think about
if you think about the fact that you
know you're Borgeous housewife in the
19th century is suddenly not required to
be a farmer's wife anymore
um and and in a sense in a sense her
role has got easier because she doesn't
have to spend you know 16 hours a day
kind of on on grinding manual labor
whilst also watching kids
um but on the other hand her role has
also shrunk because she's no longer
economically productive in a sense she's
now she's now dependent on her husband
and that com that at scale you know like
like I said you know when I was a
stay-at-home mom I had a I had a pretty
nice life because we could afford to
live on on one income and I had a good
relationship with my husband but you
know for for women where that wasn't the
case in the 19th century
um you know that's it's all very well if
you've got a if you've got a good
relationship with your spouse and you've
got funds but what happens if your
husband drinks all the money what
happens if he beats you and you're still
living under a legal regime which is
which is designed for productive
households where women wield a measure
of informal power and they're also
economically productive members of the
household
um and and suddenly you've got these
totally economically dependent
female role in the 19th century
um where where but but but women in this
situation are not they're not legally
allowed to earn property they give up
all of their property to their husband
when they get married because that was
how it worked in the pre-modern era you
know you became uh you became an
economically productive household and
that was
and that and and women had enough clout
in an informal way just I think on the
whole world more or less make that work
but in the in the industrial era
suddenly they were radically
disempowered relative to the way things
had worked before
um and and for women who found
themselves in an unhappy marriage that
was it was awful and they were like oh
you know if I leave him I have to leave
my children behind and I have no I've
got no claim to my children I can't
divorce him oh it's almost impossible to
divorce him and I can't I won't have any
property he can leave me destitute
um you know it's a it's a terrible
situation so obviously women start you
know the words all of this agitation for
a legal personhood independently of
their husbands also you know the married
women's property act which I think is
late 19th century in England and there's
an equivalent one on similar time in
America
um then there's there's all of these
campaigns the sort of first wave
feminists for for legal legal and
cultural remedies to try and offset
um the the disadvantages that women had
been left with as a result of this
massive kind of Social and economic
change so really really I mean this is
this is just to kind of explain what I
mean when I say feminism isn't it's not
it's not moral progress and people
saying oh okay now we see we were doing
it badly before because we were Wicked
people it's it's it's Downstream of much
much larger
um material changes
um and the ways the way societies have
to adapt in aggregate particularly the
way the way the relations between the
Sexes had to adapt in the context of
that and the way and and women in
particular pushed for changes to the law
and to social norms um in response to
what they understood their interest how
they saw their interests to have changed
and of course that's where it gets
really complicated as well because not
all you know not all women are created
the same you know Posh women and
working-class women don't necessarily
have the same interests and at that
point you know feminism starts to you
know it starts to multiply and become
extremely fractious and that was one of
the biggest lessons I think I learned
from you the last time that we spoke
which was that some of the uh
emancipation of women and men from
previous expectations for instance
chivalry amongst men the fact that men
were expected to maybe hold the door
open for women or to be protectors
preservers providers for women
if you get rid of that and you are a
woman in a relationship with a man who's
maybe had strong male role models in the
household and has been through higher
education and has done all of these
things and has a good moral compass
maybe that does open up a more fluid and
colorful enjoyable way of living but if
you are a woman who is perhaps in the
underclass who is with a partner who
didn't have such tight constraints on
what he considered to be good behavior
and didn't have the same sort of good
male role models what is the
justification for your husband not
hitting you anymore like how much baby
bath water and bath has been thrown out
of the window here and that I mean that
that just blows my mind and again
um talking about feminism or women as
one big hegemon right one big block that
you are trying to fit okay we'll do this
thing that is good for all women it's
like well no it's going to be good for
some women on average and bad for other
women on average and because the ones
that wield the most power culturally
intellectually tend to be the ones
toward the top of that Echelon they are
the ones that this sort of system seems
to be optimized for and it forgets the
women in the working class absolutely
and I can I can point to examples of
that from from all going back some time
put it that way I forget I forget the
exact legal contest but there's a there
was a there was a legislative battle in
the early 20th century with feminists on
both sides over the over the regulation
over workplace regulations in factories
um and though there were
feminists on one side who were looking
at working-class women on Factory
assembly lines and saying no obviously
we need to have we need to differentiate
workplace regulations by sex because
we're looking we're looking at what it's
like working on a factory floor and you
know obviously if you're built like you
Chris you know you can work a 12-hour
day doing something physically quite
demanding and it will have one set of if
you know you'll be tired at the end of
the day but it'll be once you know and
if you're but if you're five foot four
and female
um on possible or potentially pregnant
or something like that it's going to be
a completely different experience for
you and so you know things like the
length of the length of the shift and
how long your brakes should be and you
know how how they how workplace safety
ought to have been configured and and
these women are saying these feminists
were saying no obviously we need to have
sex we need to differentiate by sex in
the workplace and then the word there
are other feminists who wanted who
wanted to be treated equally in a
clerical workplace so for example as a
lawyer
um they wanted to go and have and Lead
professional lives as lawyers or
accountants or something and they were
saying no no absolutely we can't have
this you know this is absolutely no way
we can have this because otherwise that
opens the door for all sorts of
discrimination against us in the
workplace this is a disaster we can't
have this I mean you can you can see you
can see the kind of class tension right
there you know and it's and and what
ended up happening was I think was that
the the middle class feminists won and
they won with the backing of some male
industrialists
and you just think there's a there's a
parrot there's a parable there that has
been that has been repeated a number of
times since and I think is being played
out now
um in the the gender ideology debate I
think that's a rerun of essentially the
same the same drama it's the same thing
with uh we'll get on to it later but
mail uh on the Single Sex spaces as well
right
the concern around male Single Sex
spaces is because
a law graduate number 3001 lady that's
been through her higher education is
concerned that there is going to be some
gilded door behind which she can't get
into but what it's stopping is a number
of men toward the bottom end of the
distribution from having a working man's
club where they can go and you know have
30 minutes or an hour on an evening to
have a quick pint with the lads okay so
rolling the clock forward from 1800 into
1900 what is the story of the unpaid
debts that start to accrue for feminism
throughout that time
laughs
well I mean I
where I've where I think the clock
really starts ticking is when is where
you take you take the sort of Paradigm
of women's women's emancipation from
all of the things or all of the ways
that you know that life has been
gendered and constrained and you and you
take that campaign that the the feminism
of Freedom if you like I mean I've been
I I think what you need to say like this
this camp this this process of women
demand you know calling for adjustments
to the way we live together you know
throughout the industrial era
um it was justified I hope I've sort of
made the case for that you know there
was there was a lot of it that was
completely legitimate and made sense
um but all and all and what I find what
I found interesting was that there are
sort of Two Poles of it which I I just
saw coming through again and again you
know very very crudely you could call it
the feminism of care or interdependence
of the feminism of Freedom you know and
these are and I mean you know it's a
it's an enormously Rich debate and
there's plenty of internal conflict
between different groups of women who
thought different things mattered most
um but broadly speaking there are you
know there's that there are the voices
who say no actually you know we we need
to we need to accept that you know women
are mothers and we you know we we live
in relationship and this this stuff
matters and the work you know the work
of caring for dependence is important
and that's part of being a woman as part
of being a mother and then there were
other women who said no actually what we
want is what what's what's in what
women's interests look like being able
to enter the market and into public life
on the same terms as men
um and what the moment once you start
breaking those down in a bit more detail
there's a lot of tension between them
because you know obviously if you if you
have if you have a public if you live
you you you engage in public life to
take an extreme example if you work as
an MP you know if you're if you're
breastfeeding you know that that
obviously and you have an all-night
debate you know you've got a problem you
know at a point it becomes zero so
you get these sort of ridiculous stories
about you know high-powered Executives
having have pumping breast milk and then
flabbing it flown home so that their
Nanny can yeah
um you know but obviously at a point at
some point at some point being a mother
and and you know very high powered
public life is a zero-sum contest but
but broadly speaking you've got these
two poles the feminism of care and the
feminism of um Freedom
um and where I think the rubber really
starts to hit the road in terms of
um
tensions is
where I've said where I think the
feminism of Freedom definitively won you
know that was a battle that ran from the
mid-18th century in Britain up to the
mid-1960s and then in the 60s in both
Britain and America the what changed it
was another technology transition
um
but two two new developments we're
namely the contraceptive Revolution and
the digital Revolution and after you
know after that just nothing is the same
it's a new era we don't we no longer
live in the industrial era
um you know elsewhere I've not not in
the book but elsewhere I've argued that
now we live in the transhuman era which
is to say the all the cyborg era I think
I've called it in the book you know the
which which is the same thing really
um you know to uh to a degree what once
once women embraced the contraceptive
pill as a sort of basic precondition for
personhood on the same terms as men
um you know that that effectively makes
you a cyborg in the sense that your your
personhood is inseparable from a
technology
you say as well the the reason that
that's transhumanism is that instead of
Medical Care being predicated on trying
to fix a problem it's predicated on
trying to fix something which is natural
right exactly it's it's premised on
upgrading normal rather than just
restoring restoring you to normal
okay so the legislation of abortion
introduction of the pill fundamental
hinge fundamental hinge moment and I
think the the degree to which that just
changed everything is still underpriced
and my great friend Louise Perry has
done has done a fairly solid analysis on
on just how many ways you know from a
from a really quite sort of left
feminist perspective of some some of the
undercounted costs of that and of the
sexual Revolution that followed
um particularly for women did you see um
I want to inject that did you see the
clip that went it's currently still
going semi-viral between her and
Peterson and it's about uh
men that are forcing themselves on women
and a bunch of very far left YouTubers
have responded to this have you seen
this you don't spend as much time on the
internet as me no I I actually haven't I
actually haven't viewed it although
although there's been some discussion of
it in my circle the base British women's
group chat is yeah there's been there's
been some discussion of it but I
actually haven't seen the clip it's half
term and so I've been less extremely
online than you've got you okay well
it's Sam Sam Cedar is the main person
that's done this and then it got uh like
signal boosted by Ethan Klein from h3h3
and blah blah blah it's all they're all
internet people that you don't need to
worry yourself with you you can keep
writing nice things but
um
given Louise's background and your
background as well as like the most card
carrying
I I I've served my time in the trenches
doing the reading living in the places
having the hair cut you know like doing
the full thing full thing
um it it really does it almost feels
like horseshoe Theory to me a little bit
the the people who now are supposed to
be uh the most for women right the ones
that are um ostensibly helping women on
the internet especially male
left-leaning contributors
are the ones that when a woman from the
left who has been through the ringer so
to speak with regards to this ideology
and come out the other side and is now
perhaps a mother or you know Nina power
is one of your friends like who still
has this uh approach but isn't coming at
it from quite so much of a family side
um
they still get dragged
and Ethan Klein one of the reasons that
I think he's
he made a video responding to that lady
who had her digital deep fake porn video
leaked on the internet and then cried on
stream she's one of the biggest female
streamers in the world cried about it
and then Ethan uh Ally to women laughed
for like 30 seconds or a full minute
with his entire crew and then played
some theme song and he got dude like you
don't get to play Both Sides you don't
get to be the edgy comedian and also the
Ally to women and then when Louise and
Jordan are trying to play around with
ideas that are a little bit difficult as
soon as you're talking about four sex
and stuff but
and Jordan was saying maybe we need to
make it even more uh the repercussions
of a man doing this even worse
and for you to pop up as if you're like
white nighting for all of the oppressed
women out there it's like bro I remember
only two weeks ago you were laughing at
a girl who cried because her nudes deep
fake nudes are on the internet like you
don't get to do that I'll I'll just I'll
I'll only say one thing about this Chris
um a little while ago
um I wrote something about a problem
that's been puzzling me for a lot for a
while which is why it is that so many
self-styled male feminists end up having
a sex pest scandal
um I I wrote I wrote the article unheard
make me made me take out all of the
links to rumors of this of this nature
because there were so many of them and
some of them were really quite famous
names but but really it's a very very
very very very very consistent pattern
now obviously I'm not making any
imputations at all about any of the
names that you've mentioned here because
I have no idea who these people are but
um it's a very consistent pattern and
it's one of these it's it's just it's
just interesting that's all I'll say
there's a there's a curious Paradox
there and I think it's it's probably one
one that needs
um further exploration my I in as much
as I have a hypothesis about it it's
that it's just you know they're if
they're mistaken
um it's because they've been LED astray
by the idea that men and women's
sexuality is fundamentally the same
which is just obviously not true and you
know I can see how somebody would end up
accidentally could and could end up
being accidentally a sexist if they just
assumed that women have the same
approach to sex as men
um and it's all you know the more the
more cynical interpretation of it would
be that though there is a subset of men
for whom it works as a kind of as kind
of a little bit like a doctor syndrome
yeah it's a way it's a way of making
yourself seem seem more benign and
harmless when Perhaps Perhaps there are
other things going on as well I don't
know anyway but that but that's all I'll
really say about the white Knights
um as a class so uh abortion
contraceptive contraceptive pill yeah
we'll switch from White Knights to
abortion exactly moving on from
insulting an entire demographic let's go
on to something strange killing babies
[Laughter]
um laugh it's not funny getting babies
really isn't funny not funny we're
trying not to laugh about it
um
legislation abortion gets introduced
pill gets introduced emancipates women
from having
babies upon having sex then the sexual
Revolution comes along as cultural
technology to try and emancipate women
from having feelings when they have sex
and fully bifurcate everything so that
they can be the disembodied sex hole
that all women's Freedom has always
wanted them to be
I'm not sure that's quite how I'd frame
it but in practice if that's sort of
what ended up happening I suppose
I think I think that's more of the sort
of crisp spin on on what's been going on
but you know something something like
that has kind of in practice ended up
happening I mean the the the set the the
feminists of the of the second wave all
sincerely thought that the sexual
Revolution was going to be wonderful in
emancipatory you know there's loads in
Jermaine Greer and you know plenty of
other writers of that of that generation
who just sort of took a very optimistic
libertarian
um approach to to the sexual Revolution
and and believed that it was it was now
that now that we could
um emancipate ourselves from the
consequences of of sex you know and and
just untreated as a sort of leisure
activity rather than as I said there's a
very consequential thing that needed
careful um careful management you know
at a social level lest It produced sort
of long-term Social Challenges at scale
um that therefore that that would mean
you know sex could just be emancipated
in in its entirety and we would all end
up in this sort of marvelous kind of
polymorphous zone of erogenous giant
everybody you know and the thousand
flowers were Bloom and it would be great
and in practice it hasn't really worked
out like that
um because it turns out that it's harder
to abolish human nature than what it's
the polymorphous erogenous zone of orgy
Joy or whatever it was that you came up
with brilliant yeah well I mean you know
I mean it's kind of what we have but but
I think but but the point that I wanted
to make in feminism against progress is
that we have the the the mistake that
those guys made was imagining that we
could have that but without but but
without the market
they all thought that we could have the
polymorphous erogenous zone of orgy Joy
or whatever it was that I just said um
and that we and that somehow this you
know Commerce you know grubby commas
wouldn't get its fingers in but what do
you mean Commerce what do you mean
Market oh what I what I mean by that is
that it's it's become increasingly clear
to me as I've looked into the history of
um
well really the history of Technology
um you know without sort of going on too
lengthy or detour but you know in as
much as in as much as the
the modern world has become Freer
normally it's because something that
used to be just a thing that we were
stuck with
um has been replaced by biotechnology so
you know we used to be you know most
people used to be stuck with walking
everywhere and so like getting anywhere
took a certain amount of time you know
you you introduce a bunch of
Technologies into the picture like that
you know people are suddenly Freer to
get from A to B more quickly I'm taking
a very very simple example
um but
but but that it doesn't come cost free
and one of the one of the costs is is
just is quite literally the market moves
in to
well I think what I'm trying to say
freedom and trade are impossible to
separate you know the moment the more
freedom you have the more trade you'll
have because the moment the moment
something is liberated from the social
norms that that governed it before
um and become something that you can
that you can buy or sell people will buy
and sell it what's an example of how
that worked with regards to sex or
relationships well I mean if you the the
first Playboy club opened the year the
pill was legalized
um I think that's I think it actually I
mean if we're going to be really
pedantic I think the first Playboy club
actually opened a about six months
before the pill was legalized but I mean
it was pretty much there already at that
point
um and by by the by the 1970s radical
feminists were were running
demonstrations against the the level of
violence and degradation that was now
you know increasingly endemic in the
porn industry and and the
and and the the important industry
existing I mean you know there has
always been pornography you know to to
an extent but the porn but the porn
industry being able to present itself in
in libertarian terms is predicated on
the idea that sex is consequence free
and therefore is a private matter and
the idea of sex Being A Private Matter
is predicated on the technology existing
that that makes it possible for it to be
a private matter which is to say a
contraception because if there's no
contraception sex isn't A Private Matter
you know the rest of your village really
does have skin in the game about who you
sleep with right
um because particularly if you're female
and you could end up with an unwanted
baby and which people have got to figure
out what to do with so you know if
there's if sex is a consequential thing
like you know it's it's not A Private
Matter it just isn't do you think
rolling the clock forward from that
do you think that there was a particular
hinge or a unique hinge point with the
introduction of only fans with the fact
that you had a particularly frictionless
D to C
normal person to audience member
platform for things I don't know I think
I mean I I think only fans is a long way
down the slippery slope to be honest
um I mean the
the the the hinge moment is probably is
probably online dating as such because I
mean once you've once you've got used to
the idea of you know packaging yourself
as a kind of product in an online
Marketplace which is essentially what
you're doing when you create a dating
profile you know it's not you know I've
I've run I've done like digital Commerce
for for clients back in the days when I
worked in marketing you know and doing
that creating a dating profiler they're
not that different really you know at
the end of the day your your marketing
something you know you're creating an
appealing package which is designed to
to to to cause somebody to click
um and you know what happens at the
checkout after the checkout process is
supposed to be different but actually
you know there's it's once you've got to
the idea that you're that you're you're
pressing you're browsing a set of
products and then you're clicking on one
that you like the look of and then you
know in a sense you're sort of checking
out the product you know it's just not
it's just not a very big step from that
to you know kind of you know online
dating as parasocial relationship and
it's not a great big step from that to
you know that is a sort of subscription
product you know I think I I think the
beginning of the slippery slope is
online dating as such yeah that's that
that's an interesting point that it's
probably a difference of degree not a
difference of kind particularly I mean
yes yes there is a you know the point at
which you're saying no actually I'm
going to press I'm going to press buy
rather than I'm just going to press like
hey hey baby hey baby how's it going you
know message this person yes that's that
that's a qualitative difference but it's
not it's not a very big one you know but
no I think you know once the rest of the
Paradigm is in place it's not a very big
one before we start talking about cyborg
theocracy is there anything else that we
need to understand about the foundation
of how we got here
I mean I think the the critical the
critical points are feminism isn't about
moral progress as such it's a response
to material conditions
um you know the industrial the
industrial era was a set of massive
transformations in material conditions
and first and second wave first first
way feminism really was a response to
those material conditions but everything
changed with the digital and
contraceptive revolutions and you know
and and second way feminism was I
suppose a a response to that but
everything which has come since I think
is qualitatively different because it no
longer really has very much space at all
for the feminism of care
um it's almost almost all of it is about
the feminism of Freedom which is to say
um and and it's all fundamentally in
it it has it has this this premise of
um Freedom underwritten by yeah Freedom
underwritten by technology baked into it
which is to say it's all it's all
underwritten by contraception and the
and the final backstop of that has to be
abortion
um and really what you're saying when
you legalize abortion is that a woman's
freedom is is that important when a
woman's personhood you know it's it's
it's it's sufficiently important to
the to women's political participation
that they be free and unencumbered that
they can pursue that even to the extent
of ending the life of an unborn child
uh does that make sense yeah absolutely
and really you know what what however
wherever you stand in relation to that
you you know I think you we could all
accept that that's a very strong
statement to make in favor of Freedom
you know where that comes into direct
conflict with the with the needs of a
dependent other well do you think so I I
really like that that summary that
feminism wasn't about progress it was
about the response to changes in
technology and uh sort of society at
Large
what what has been the fuel that has
continued to push
feminist progress
but through the 60s right through to now
you know still going stronger than ever
is this uh just like a mimetic echo of a
time when we were forging forth is it
performative empathy that is being
driven by online
well I I asked myself that and I think
this is probably not a single answer to
that I mean one of what one one factor
is surely you know that having having
all agreed sort of collectively and this
is a meme that's much bigger than
feminism having all agreed collectively
that more freedom is generally better uh
we've said we've just gone on pursuing
that blue sky Vision yeah yeah you know
that more more Liberation is just better
by definition and and also that more
more technology will and more more
economic growth more technology more
Innovation will will deliver us more
freedom which is which is obviously good
you know that's a kind of unstated
unstated premise of you know most of the
20th century going into the 21st century
I would argue it's kind of there it's
there in the water you know it's so so
kind of you know well dissolved that you
know we you don't even really you don't
don't even really think about it it's
just it's just there in the water
um
and just just the other point that I
would underline
um is that
thank you every time you use technology
to afford yourself more freedom or more
Innovation or more growth
um you don't as you you can't you don't
as a consequence of that end up
abolishing whatever it was that you were
trying to emancipate yourself from
before so so if for example you're using
a technology to flatten the differences
between men and women in reproductive
terms that doesn't end up abolishing
that doesn't end up abolishing human
nature you know men and women remain
different even if we've used used a
technology to flatten some of those
differences and that that really that
and all we've ended up doing is
reordering those differences to the
market so they become supply and demand
problems or they become strategic
vulnerabilities and I suppose that that
really sort of leads leads on to what
I've called cyborg theocracy it's
my name I should I I really need to
reiterate this I I owe the meme to a to
a magnificent Albanian called audientola
who you you've probably who you probably
know
um who for whom yeah who just kind of
threw it out there and I'm like this
this is this is this is such a great
description and when I want to talk
about cyborg theocracy I mean
yeah how do I how do I put this
um I mean the moral order which
legitimizes the world view which I've
been trying to describe
um in which the the good is just
understood to be the pursuit of ever
more Freedom underwritten by technology
um
that sounds it sounds very dry and very
abstract put in those terms but it's it
it has a lot more it has more teeth than
that well you've got the war on
relationships between men and women as
one big component of this so what would
be an example of how that's manifested
okay so so I've I've I've I've looked at
um in in the book I've looked at three
three aspects of
um human nature as I as I see it which
which were now Waging War on you know
having having got to having got to the
the end of the easy wins in in terms of
in terms of where industrial technology
can can get us too
um my my the one with the way I see the
the turn the the cyborg turn is that you
know we've sort of finished
industrializing the world and we've
pretty much run out of you know places
to colonize and natural resources to
exploit and you know rivers to pollution
so on and so forth but the same you know
that that sort of Relentless onward
March and that Relentless kind of you
know exploratory energy it hasn't hasn't
stopped and what it's done instead is
it's turned inwards so it's turned it's
it's sort of turned inward towards
colonizing the human body and turned
inward towards colonizing and exploiting
the human soul and so and through
variously biomedical advances and
digital technology and and the former is
really really about
um commodifying the human body and the
latter is is about modifying the human
soul so the domain of ideas and the
domain of sociality
um
and because because the sort of the
fundamental premises that we can we can
use more technology to deliver more
freedom and this is going to result in
you know more more money and also more
more Felicity somehow
um what's Felicity I mean joy happiness
well-being goodness you know the good
stuff
um having having
delivered all of our easy wins
um where now we're Now setting about
abolishing slightly trickier
um aspects of human nature so we've done
our best to abolish the difference
between the Sexes so nowhere and and so
now we're Waging War on the relationship
between the Sexes you know how people
you know the
the the dance of courtship if you like
the the the domain of sexual desire show
me how that's manifested how's that
happened
um so
really that what what that looks like is
the the sort of slow breakdown since the
contraceptive revolution of
of any sort of groundedness to why why
we why we why we [__] you know why why
we experience desire you know there's
there's a sort of slow slow
disintegration of the idea that it's
ordered to anything let alone fertility
uh let alone sort of you know
relationship formation and having
children and you know increasingly this
idea that it's a sort of it's It's a
property of whoever it is who you know
it what what I do with my sexuality is
my own business and therefore you know
what I choose to point it at is also my
own business
um and while while you could say well
you know of course it's some well what
what somebody what somebody chooses to
beat off to in the privacy of their own
home is their own business
um
but I've but I've done my best to show
how actually at scale the
the larger consequences of that in terms
of how it how it affects the way people
form relationships even when people
really long to form relationships and
even when people long for a long-term
partner is actually
it's it's enormous
um and if you if if you propagate this
idea that really people can just you
know do people can just do whatever they
want then people really will do whatever
they want and particularly when you when
you when you reinforce this with you
know been an endemic sort of an endemic
online pornography and you know
pervasive cultural message that says
commodifying yourself even to the point
of making yourself a subscription
product on only fans is not only
legitimate but it's also empowering
um it it leaves people in the situation
where you've got this incredibly kind of
adversarial and Incredibly hostile and
Incredibly exploitative dynamic between
the Sexes such that it's now almost
impossible to to extend enough trust and
enough vulnerability I think to another
person to be willing to take the risk of
um loving someone and I think that's
that's catastrophic over the long term
for people just being able to you know
find happiness or kids or anything
really do you think that this is
contributing to one of the reasons that
fewer young people than ever are having
sex that very likely yeah yeah I mean
it just seems Seems chaotic
um disorganized and frightening
um you know and if you're I mean
honestly if I were if I were 22 now and
all of the guys I was I was potentially
I could be potentially dating had been
marinated in porn since they were 11. I
might be I I'd probably just take up
macrame instead because I mean at the
end of the day you're probably not going
to have a nice time you know and if if
the presumption is it's just going to be
a casual hookup you only have a 10 of 10
chance of orgasm anyway so I mean why
wouldn't you just stay at home and do
macrame or I don't know start and only
fans yeah you know in a way I I don't I
don't blame them I don't blame them for
for just opting out voting with their
feet it sounds it seems hellish so the
uh sacredness around not only sex not
only what it meant physically in terms
of making babies not only what it meant
emotionally in terms of a connection but
then even before you get to marriage the
um holder the placeholder the um
space within which sex was typically
happening which is relationships that
was also put into war and then
Downstream from that the relationship
between mothers and babies was also
Center War
yeah I mean that's a that's a very uh
that that starts from us from a slightly
different place
um but I mean let me see where how do I
talk about the war the war on
relationships between mothers and babies
I mean that's a
that's
well I mean put it this way but I mean I
was I was I used to have recurring
nightmares about having about accidental
pregnancy
um I can still remember it in my 20s I'd
just wake up in a cold sweat um
I don't think I'm alone in that
um
and it's it's not just it's not just the
prospect of sort of being left literally
holding the baby
um there's there's some you know if
you've
what what I've tried to show is this
this sense this increasingly strong
sense I've had that a lot of the
pro-choice activism which is around now
much more so than was the case even even
15 or 20 years ago but a lot of the
women who are who are campaigning for
the right to abort babies now are doing
so because they're viscerally frightened
by the prospect of pregnancy there's
something so horrifying about the idea
of letting that happen to your body for
a lot of women and I see it I mean this
is I couldn't point you to point you to
a particular tweet but but I see them a
lot you know there's it's this is
there's a there's a growing constituency
of young women For Whom the idea of the
idea of being pregnant is you know the
response is body horror you you know
it's like it's like the sort of H.R
Geiger kind of you know xenomorph that
you know bursts its way out of your chat
you know the the responses in that sort
of order it's not a kind of it's not
perceived as a wonderful thing at all
why do you think it is
um like I've been trying to understand
it I've been trying to get my head
around what's going on there and I think
it has to do
um yeah with
just how radically everyone is expected
to be self-contained now just how
radically everyone is you know
the The Good the right the you know they
the fight the good upstanding person is
supposed to be completely atomized you
know you're not it's it's shameful but
to depend on somebody else it's shameful
to be vulnerable it's shameful to be
weak
um it's shameful to
um
you you have to be in command of all of
your own [__] all the time that just
seems it that that seems to be a sort of
basic expectation and if you're not if
you're not willing to
if you need other people you're you
failed that seems that seems to be the
sort of basic basic presumption and
fundamentally you can't be pregnant and
not need other people you know that that
just doesn't work oh so the getting
pregnant is an amplifying of
fragility around your own personal
sovereignty
probably a good way of putting it and
also
I mean you know if you think about the
premium there are some much more sort of
basic things as well you think about the
premium that's
that's on looking a certain way and we
also think about the the premium or
that's the song controlling your
physiology and controlling your
appearance I mean you know even just not
being fat is a massive Flex you know in
the the Instagram World
um you know and then
you add you know a series of totally
involuntary bodily changes into that and
you can see how people would react with
just total body horror I mean look at
the Kardashians look at what they do
they go the full surrogate route right
right right and and this is the and this
is really where the the war on the war
on relationship between mothers and
babies that the rubber hits the road
because once you start
um
it
once you accept the basic premise that
women's
autonomy as atomized individuals and
atomized Market participants is so
politically important that it's
commercialized medical interventions
into your body as the route towards
emancipation and once once you've
started down that road then you think
well why should it stop what why should
it stop with level with controlling my
fertility why should it stop with
underwriting my autonomy by by ending an
accidental pregnancy why shouldn't I
extend that to all of the other ways
that biomedical Technologies can can
alleviate the burden of motherhood
because it is it's a considerable burden
I mean I reached escape velocity from
atomized life too late to have more than
one child but you know I nearly died in
the process of giving birth to her and
I'm I'm grateful to Modern you know I
spend a lot of time dunking on on
medicine and but dunking on you know
modern modern Technologies but honestly
I wouldn't be here that's the only
reason that you're here is because of
the byproduct of those right right well
well yeah well yes and no I mean but I
won't I I won't bore you with with that
that's kind of a side issue the the
point is you know what what why why stop
with controlling fertility why stop with
underwriting women's Freedom through
abortion why not extend why not extend
the market further into into the the
reproductive domain why not why not
commodify more of it why not seek to
control more of it and at that point you
you think well well why why should I not
why should why shouldn't we have a
market in gametes why shouldn't we have
IVF why shouldn't we have gestational
surrogacy why shouldn't we cut all of
those piece cut it all into pieces and
buy and sell sell each of the pieces
individually like why not what would you
say to the women listening that say well
I don't want to have unplanned
pregnancies I want to be able to control
my own reproduction with birth control
or with abortion or with uh maybe I'm uh
I value my career a lot and I want to
Outsource having a child to a surrogate
um yeah well the the there are several
there are several points in there let's
take them one by one I mean you know if
you want to if you want to control your
fertility there is always the option of
not having sex I'll just I'll just put
that out there you know
um but you know and if you if you do
want to have sex you know you have a
choice you can either you can either be
doing it in a committed relationship or
you can do cycle tracking or you can or
or you can or you can use you know one
of those other methods and
um I'm not saying don't do it but what
I'm look what I've what I've sought to
tease out is some of the larger scale
undercounted side effects of taking the
route that we've taken and and maybe
maybe weighing and asking the question
you know how much how much how many of
how much of this
um is is really a route that we want to
be going down and and there are there I
dare say there will be women watching it
was like well you know I don't really
care about any of these undercounter
side effects and you know [__] off Mary
I'm not going to read your book
um why would I want to do that so I'm
fine with things as they are in which
case you know
I guess there's not a great deal more I
can say to you but but I mean the only
thing I would say to somebody who who's
considering gestational surrogacy just
because they don't fancy stretch marks
or they don't want to interrupt their
career is that pregnancy doesn't just
create a baby it also creates a mother
um it pregnancy realize the mother's
brain in irreversible ways and primes
her for caretaking in ways which are
just not repeatable
um if you haven't been through that
process and this is not to say that
adoptive parents can't be great
caretakers because there's a certain
there's evidence that some of the same
changes take place albeit more slowly in
non-non-gestational caretakers but if
you want to if you want to fast forward
that process and optimize yourself for
being a mother you should just be a
mother and that's quite aside from the
obviously well yeah the the exploitative
um and you know other other potentially
harmful I went down a rabbit hole after
reading about a gay couple in New York
who wanted to get
surrogacy on Health medical insurance
because they said that their sexuality
was a form of impotence or infertility
right um and and that I'd never
considered the ethics of surrogacy
before uh but I I seem to remember that
someone said it was the same as
Financial blackmail uh but done in
Reverse to some of the surrogate mothers
for him it's an amount of money offered
to the women some of the women from some
of the couples that is so great that
they essentially can't say no to it and
they do have things like it can't be
your first child
um you have to go through a bunch of
tests and they do background checks and
they do blah blah blah but still I'm
really conflicted over the surrogacy
thing at the moment I'm kind of like uh
whatever is apogee when I'm like
weightless and I just have no idea
what's going on I really haven't done
enough but I certainly know that I'm not
like just blue sky totally open for it
and I absolutely love that quote that
pregnancy doesn't just create a child it
also creates a mother
um
yeah I I it's it's so
strange to think about what happens
as a byproduct of something that
medically could be useful within certain
circumstances when culturally it just
gets uh like
spread out leveraged scaled uh
unbelievable speed
yeah I mean certainly my my experience
of being a new mum was that my baby
didn't feel like a separate person to me
for first really some time afterwards
you know it was like it was like I'd
grown an extra limb or like grown I mean
I had literally like grown her inside my
body and it felt like one of some part
of my body was just bizarrely separate
from me now but but I still I still
needed to take care of it as I was you
know another arm or a leg or something
it was a really really strange feeling
and and you you know and you're no
longer getting the direct feedback from
this that but it's still literally part
of you it feels like part of your own
body and it's not it's a separate it's
it's this baby and suddenly you've got
to take care of it and try and figure
out what it needs the whole time
um but but it's like she didn't feel
like a separate person to me for a very
long time and I get that there are
situations where babies can't be cared
for by their gestational mothers you
know there are you know accidents happen
and disasters happen and you know
extremely ill or you know psychically
distressed and others happen and so on
and so forth you know there are like
things can go wrong but to me it's just
it's just obviously immoral to to
conceive a child with the intent of
separating him or her from from that
Bond the moment the moment he or she is
born it just seems Seems profoundly
wrong to me and doing that doing that in
the inter commercially you know for
profit just feels really quite something
unpleasant to me yeah something super
icky okay so there's something really
nice about that final war the final war
between women and their bodies yeah the
the relationship between all of us and
our bodies really I mean but um I think
it's particularly acute for young people
and it's particularly acute for
adolescent girls but yeah I think you
know once you start once you accept the
premise that we can use technology to
just continue emancipating ourselves
indefinitely then you know why why
should we why shouldn't we extend beyond
controlling our fertility to flattening
all the differences between the sexism
why shouldn't we extend beyond that
again to the idea that we can remodel
our bodies as we see fit
um in any way in any way we choose and
really the bow wave that is is the the
activist you know movement the activist
granswell for um freedom of gender
I suppose to use a phrase from Martian
rothblatt who's a very who's a very
well-known transgender activist and
transhumanist activist
um rothblatt has written a book called
from transgender to transhuman a
Manifesto for freedom of form
which argues that
um the the freedom to be to present you
know with whatever secondary sex
characteristics we choose and that most
aligns with our sense of self is only
the precursor to they are much more
radical freedom to just present
physiologically however we like you know
if we wanted to grow a pair of horns or
a tail or extra limbs then fine you know
you should just go for it or or just to
upload ourselves digitally into the
cloud and be digital persons and that
ought to be fine as well
um and and you see when you and and
really there isn't you know it's
if if you can
if you can have whatever secondary sex
characteristics you like you know as you
as you choose then it's sort of
difficult to see why you shouldn't just
extend that way beyond that and actually
you know you're beginning to see that in
some of the gender clinics where you
know a far greater variety of surgeries
is on offer so I sat next to a dinner I
mean don't Google
about a month and a half ago the number
one transgender surgeon in America this
guy does between 300 and 400 transgender
surgeries per year and he owns a clinic
that does over a thousand a number of
clinics actually that are around the
country and uh I was incredibly
surprised by him like unbelievably
surprised zero ideology absolutely no I
not ideologically captured at all I
didn't I was the first time that I'd met
this entire group of people and I was
like I don't want to be the like so how
do you feel about the ethics like we're
having steak like just you know just
listen and maybe the second time that I
go back I'll be able to push a little
bit more
but he was mentioning some of the
different procedures that he does where
some people would like to add a penis
but also would like to keep their vagina
and a lot of the time these individuals
will come in and they'll have researched
I guess the same way as if you want to
get a fringe or something you might have
some examples of someone's Fringe that
you like and so I'm looking for a fringe
like this and apparently it's it's
borderline obsessive the well I like the
shape of you see how the head of the
penis kind of does this thing and then
toward the base it's sort of got it gets
a little bit thicker so it's like I
really really like this and he was like
with the best will in the world I'm
taking flesh from your forearm and
forming it into something that remotely
resembles a penis if it looks anything
like a penis let's call that a win do
you know this is this is insane to talk
about the transhumanist stuff do you
know how
trans penises get hard
I I have some I have some sort of um let
me tell you let me tell you in depth
it's a sort of inflating device isn't it
that's correct so there is a a pouch of
saline that is um inserted into the body
behind the bladder uh so there's a
little pouch at all times in there and
there's testicles right a penis or even
if it's made from your forearm if to
make it look like a real thing it would
have testicles one of the testicles is a
fake ball the other testicle is a pump
attached to a series of one-way valves
that goes from the pouch behind the
bladder up into the penis and it's a you
like pump it do you remember those were
they Nike don't kicks or whatever from
the 90s are you telling me that this guy
was talking you through all of this
while you were eating steak this was
after we'd finished eating steak mostly
I was gonna say yeah because it was
pretty red on steak as well so I would
have been quite uncomfortable
um but yeah and you
pump it up and then there's a CH there's
a valve that you can uh release it and
you can even fit ways to make fluid come
out of it at the opportune moment as
well uh so I did
the bodily modification is unbounded now
and um
pretty terrifying yeah and I yeah I
suppose that's that's the conclusion I
found myself coming to that I found
myself essentially coming to the same
conclusion as Martin rothblatt that this
is this is as in rothblatt's words the
on-ramped transhumanism and you may
think well fine you know let's let's all
let's all go transhumanist and you know
arguably you know on my by my own logic
given that we've been we've been in the
transhuman hysteria for over over half a
century now you know having embraced it
with the contraceptive pill why
shouldn't we just lean all the way into
it and I think well I
I suppose that that's one response sure
but I look at
I look at this transhumanist Revolution
and I think well you know the the Lefty
in me says well hang on a minute
um you know it's this is probably going
to be fine for people like the
Kardashians and or Grimes who who's just
had had another Elon Musk baby via
surrogacy because she didn't like give
have giving birth the first time
um there's this fine for people like
that but people further down the food
chain I mean what what generally what
generally happens when
when a whole new domain of Human Social
Life is enclosed and marketized is that
people at the top do really nicely and
then people further down you know find
it's it's they they get they get all all
of the disruption and very and
considerably less of the benefit and I'm
thinking well where are all these body
parts gonna come from
um you know who's going to donate all of
the uteruses to be to be transplanted
into male bodies
um and you're thinking and then I
stumbled sort of semi-unrelatedly on a
story about
um Farm Workers like female Farm Workers
in Maharashtra which is a district in
India
um who often voluntarily opt for
hysterectomies
um because it makes them more employable
if they if they don't suffer from
monthly menstrual cycles they're just
more employable and they're more likely
they're more likely to be able to get a
job in the in the agricultural gig
economy in Maharashtra if they can prove
that they've had a hysterectomy and I'm
thinking if we're if we're still if
we're starting to treat human bodies as
things as as resources which can be
disassembled and reassembled and
transplanted and you know treated like
the fleshy bits of Lego that can be
assembled as we see fit then there's
going to be a market and some people are
going to be you know one class of people
is going to be buying and another class
of people is going to be selling
um and once once you start once you
start looking seriously at the prospect
of you know creating a
creating a free market in human body
parts it's going to be the women in
Maharashtra who are selling and it's
going to be I I don't know who some some
somebody that's some some some male with
money who's going to be buying and I
just don't like the look of that you
know the the Lefty and me stands up and
says no no we have to do something about
this the Lefty and me says this is a
this is a grotesque a bomb this is this
is an abominable form of exploitation
and if if there's any way we can stand a
thought history and yell stop then we
probably should
that's pretty terrifying that's like
really really concerning and yeah and I
mean if that actually I'll I'll just
give you a more recent um United States
headline along the same lines oh I will
I'll leave you leave you more of the
stuff of nightmares a bill was recently
introduced in a U.S state I think it was
Massachusetts
um to offer convicted convicts
imprisoned incarcerated felons
um a reduction in their jail sentence if
they donate organs or bone marrow
and if if that isn't the wombless
Farm Workers of Maharashtra being you
know essentially turned into resources I
don't I don't really know what else but
I don't know I don't know what it is
um
and again you know that the Lefty in me
says that if there's any way we can be
standing a thought history yelling stop
yeah
facing this this kind of this this sort
of stuff being just normalized into into
our economies and normalized into the
way we see human bodies then we should
I've heard you say previously with
regards to the Lefty thing
um that Occupy Wall Street failed as we
tried to take back control of our
finances from people that were in
control of the market and right now we
have the opportunity to take back
sovereignty of our bodies from people
that are trying to marketize them as
well
yeah I think we need and occupy
ourselves yeah movement but why is it
the case that other people from the left
who ostensibly are so anti-capitalist
haven't clocked on to the downstream
implications of what this philosophy
taken to its extreme would mean for our
bodies like the capitalization of the
self
I think some of them some of them have
in for in a lot of the time there's a
real cognitive dissonance around
um I mean to be honest there's a there's
an immense cognitive dissonance on both
the left and the right when it comes to
technology
um you know I think the the right is
every bit as confused about technology
as the left
um so so I'm I'm going to be I'm sort of
tossing bombs and an equal opportunities
way that I mean the right can't decide
whether it's for kind of you know
retreating to sort of tread distributism
or you know tealight space Fascism and
you know you can't I think it's very
difficult to have both although you know
maybe my friend my non-friends would
disagree with me but I think there are
some there are some tensions there
um and and they similarly there are
there are real tensions on the left
between the the desire to the desire to
use technology to create abundance in
order to emancipate everybody across the
world and the obvious negative side
effects that all of that
industrialization and emancipation and
technologization is having you know
particularly in where it comes to these
sort of asymmetric exploitation of of
you know
overseas of overseas groups and you know
colonized peoples and exploited subsets
of the population and so on
um and then and but but they but the
left can't quite give up on the
emancipatory power of technology and the
way the way it can be used as a
battering ram against
um
Authority and the right can't quite give
up on the economic promise of technology
and the way it can be used as a
battering ram against
um
used as a battering ram against the the
promise that we really ever have to have
any limits at all everybody everybody
wants to use technology to escape our
own limits on both the the right and the
left just come at it differently and so
it's so strange to think what the
externalities are of lots of freedom
of like too much freedom and I it's
something it's a question I I really
really don't do the sort of
socio-political cultural intersection
particularly while human nature good
like individuals small groups yes but as
soon as I scale it up I'm essentially
useless but I do know that there is an
interesting question about too much
Freedom what does it mean to have too
much Freedom what does it mean for the
degrees of play within a system to be to
be infinite or zero basically
um yeah and I do know that that that's
dangerous
um yeah
and my view is that we it
the the conservatives who think that
everything that's wrong with the way we
are now it could be fixed by just
changing what women do and leaving
everything else the same they're wrong
um they're just they're just not
thinking about it right because you know
we're not there is no going back you
know that there is no return it just
isn't happening and just saying well we
can we can just keep everything the same
except what women do isn't going to
produce the result that they want at all
um
but but everybody you know but we we
need we all need a freedom haircut men
and women both and that's going to take
that that that's going to take I've
already done mine I've already I've gone
full V for Vendetta okay so
um
big romance your other large Behemoth
that you want to try and attack abolish
big romance yes what is because why do
you want to abolish it I think this is
where your interests and mine sort of
collide don't they Chris because you're
you're
very very preoccupied with the The
Mating crisis and and really this is
abolish big romances I suppose my
my take on how we got to the mating
crisis
I mean you know I don't want to I don't
want to do a whole nother social history
lesson because I feel like I've bothered
on about that enough already
um but the my my argument is that we how
people understood marriage what what
people understood marriage to mean has
changed a number of times over the
course of civilization you know the the
way people approach marriage now
um isn't isn't fixed isn't set in stone
you know the what people have what
people understand it to mean has changed
a great deal over over the course of
time in the Middle Ages it was a much
more pragmatic business for most people
I mean marriages where I often arranged
um you know all marriages were
contracted sort of relatively relatively
briskly and were then well and after
that were just basically impossible to
dissolve or nearly impossible to
dissolve and most people treated it as a
fairly pragmatic Arrangement
um you know because you're economically
interdependent as part of a productive
household and that's just a very
different relationship to one where
you're expected to be all sort of
lovey-dovey all the time you know at the
end of the day the the the pigs need
feeding and and some somebody's got to
get the wheat in the ground before it
rains and that and that's a very
different set of priorities than you
know did did he did he remember to pick
his socks up and you know has he has he
left has he left a little a little note
on the kitchen table for me before he
left the day and then but what what
changed with the industrial era is that
partly because women found themselves
with a great deal less economic agency
than they had done previously
um the
the preoccupation with love in a in a
relationship became proportionally
stronger as women lost agency and and it
became you know for pragmatic reasons
much more important to have a husband
who loved you you know you can have a
you can have a husband you just get on
with reasonably well and in a as a sort
of business partner if you're if you're
both you know co-producers in a in a
productive household but if you're if
you're an economic dependent
um and you're unable to own property
you're unable to divorce and you're and
you have no legal personhood really
independent from your husband they're no
way of earning money you know it's it's
considerably more in your interest to
make sure that you marry somebody who
loves you and respects you so so at the
beginning you know with the with the
rise of the economically inactive
Bourgeois housewife you get the idea of
companion romance which I mean I I don't
know if you've ever read any of the Jane
Austen novels or seen them by a bunch of
people to read them and if you're the
third the third person in the space of a
couple of months to tell me I feel like
I I probably should do apparently she
was way ahead of every evil solutionary
psychologists time in understanding
she's a superb writer and she's she's
probably the the number one
um
the the number one prophet of companion
at marriage because she was she was the
one who really set the bar for what that
was meant to look like you know I mean
the relationship between Elizabeth
Bennett and Mr Darcy in Pride and
Prejudice is it kind of sets the bar for
what one of the what a relationship like
that should look like and what it's in
women's interests to pursue under those
circumstances you know Elizabeth Bennett
is she's too much of a gentle woman ever
to earn her own living so she needs to
marry up
um but she also doesn't want to marry
somebody who doesn't like her or respect
her and and she ends up married to like
the guy she's like she's it's it's the
perfect relationship within within the
terms of what's available to her
politically and economically under those
circumstances but
um with the arrival of the Pearl and
women's entry into the workplace and so
on you know those those economic
pressures and those economic constraints
have sort of Gone Away
um you know sisters are doing it for
themselves now as the song goes you know
in in a sense you don't you don't need a
husband who loves you in fact you don't
need a husband at all you know you can
you can kind of you can do it all in
theory on your own and so you know
marriage has evolved from business sort
of the the Elizabeth Bennett and Mr
Darcy ideal to something much more sort
of consumerist you know in in the sense
that you know you're you're supposed to
be self-actualizing each other all of
the time and you're you're your partner
is supposed to be a vector for your kind
of self your self-actualization and if
and if they're not if they're not
delivering on that front you're you're
wholly entitled to just walk away at any
time for any reason and that's that's
the sort of and that's really where big
romance has got has got us it's evolved
into it's not my term but the the
self-expressive marriage so somebody
else coined the term but I think it's a
good one this idea that you know it's a
you know my my relationship expresses
and and helps me to optimize who I am as
a person and if it if it stops doing
that then I no longer I I have no no
obligation to try and sustain it and
this is
predicated on the idea that you know men
and women are just not economically
interdependent at all
you know which is just which is just
true I think in a lot of cases
well I mean at the end you know if I
have a job and and my husband also has a
job and we could both theoretically
survive independently of one another
then
you know we're not we're not really into
internet convenience well all rob you
know we're not we're not interdependent
to the point where it's just Unthinkable
to to to end the relationship you know
it's all it's it's thinkable from a sort
of material Level to end-to-end
relationships in again so this is uh
maybe another uh byproduct of a lot of
freedom but this time it's Financial
Freedom
yeah and all of that again is it is
Downstream of Social and material
changes which make it make it Much More
Much More Level pegging in terms of who
who can flourish professionally
I mean the you know
de-industeindustrialization in the west
and the rise of knowledge work has has
radically changed the balance of power
between the Sexes where it comes to
who's earning particularly for when you
go further down the economic scale let
me give you a quote that I got from
Joyce beninson a little while ago
Society is man-made and in the modern
world men have put themselves out of a
job
yeah I think that's I think that's
pretty accurate
I mean benison is a very sharp Observer
of men and women and I think I think
there's a lot of Truth in I've I've made
a similar argument
um I've made a similar yeah in a sense
men have put themselves out of a job
so you you have this uh uh whether it's
a marriage of convenience or at least
not one which is forced to be together
what would you say to the people that
say well hang on a second shouldn't
shouldn't I love my partner shouldn't I
shouldn't we make each other better
people are you telling me that I'm
supposed to settle for some sub-optimal
remote just like plausibly passable guy
that I'll spend the rest of my life with
well I would say to that you know I
wouldn't just you know don't just marry
somebody off the street that's a stupid
idea
um but
um by the same token um choosing one
person is by definition settling
because everybody everybody annoys their
partner after a while you know you live
together for long enough eventually
you'll find something about the other
person that gets up your notes it's just
I mean it's just it's just inevitable
yeah
and and to to an extent
um
choose yeah choosing one other person is
settling by definition and if you're so
hung up on the idea of infinite
optionality that you're just you're
never ever going to settle eventually
you'll you'll be left just with just
with yourself
um did I send you that Stephen Shaw
episode about the Birthright crisis
stuff yes I mean he he has this I really
want to dig into this more but four out
of five childless women didn't intend to
not have kids so around about 10 of
women physically are incapable around
about 10 of women it seems intended to
not have children which leaves 80 of
women that didn't have kids not
intending to not be mothers and this is
a meta-analysis by Professor renska
Kaiser it's a huge huge huge study
replicated across multiple demographics
across multiple countries territories
Etc
and does these support groups for women
that grieve over families that they
never had that was the the term that he
used and it just makes me like that
grieve over the family that they never
had
really really sensitive is down my spine
uh and yeah it's the optionality it's
next thing right it's peering over the
current person's shoulder to see what's
coming next just in case yeah yeah and
and it's you know when you're surrounded
the whole time by by sort of swiping
right and swiping left and you know the
world seems to be you know a washing you
know
a new a new person you could check out
from the from from the from the internet
shop of potential sexual partners and
though they seem to be infinite yeah I
can see why but
why the idea of settling would just seem
unimaginable and Unthinkable
particularly once you get to a point
where you know swiping right swiping
left is so normal that it's the the idea
of settling full stop has come has
started to seem a bit strange and I mean
you know I talked to I talk to people
younger than me who who tell me that if
you're dating now
um
there's there's just no
nobody ever talks about exclusivity it's
it's not done
to to assume you know that if you're
seeing somebody on a regular basis that
is it it used to be it used to be sort
of Taken taken as read that if you're
you know you're you've you've seen
somebody a few times then you're
probably not chugging other people and
that's kind of rude to do that like that
that was a norm even you know in the
naughties and it isn't now it's just and
no and there's no
there's a whole new set of anxieties
about even having the conversation with
somebody you've been sleeping with for
like six months and you're and then you
know after six months it's an incredibly
delicate and awkward conversation to try
and Broach you know could we maybe just
not be seeing other people and and that
that seems that seems like an extremely
back foot to be on where it comes to
like that's very very on the back foot
where it comes to trying to sort of form
a permanent relationship in the first
place let alone
um get to a point where actually you
could you could be
between you making long-term plans of
any kind at all and you know and you're
so far in that in that situation from
from being able to imagine
um the the sort of radical loyalty which
I think is the the basis for a kind of
post-romantic marriage that I yeah I I I
I really I really feel for the kids
because it just seems like a nightmare
it just seems like an absolute nightmare
balance the scales or Square the circle
for me around don't marry someone off
the street no but also know that uh post
Romance
marriage might be something that would
be good to go for
well I think the there's probably I mean
there's obviously some due diligence to
be done in terms of you know does
somebody have more does somebody share
your values does somebody share your
life goals you know does are they are
they Pleasant looking are they are they
nice to their mum that's you know if
you're a woman that's that's a good
that's a useful indicator you know do
they treat them unwell
um all of these things you know a good
and important kind of basic due
diligence to do you know don't marry
somebody off the street
um I probably don't marry somebody to
who's addicted to porn if you can
possibly avoid it you know all of those
sort of Common Sense things
um but but but fundamentally you know
are you
my view is that
the economic changes material changes
are once again going to force the issue
um and for everybody except the top the
top tier you know who can carry on
having these self-expressive marriages
if they want to because they're rich
enough to just [__] around
um but but for everybody else who's sort
of you know a bit closer to the sharp
end economically
um it's just not going to be possible to
you know end your marriage it's just not
going to be sensible to end your
marriage as the drop of a hat because
we're just going to need each other more
you know and if the world goes on
getting more dangerous and more unstable
and more expensive
um you know being being interdependent
is just a better way to be it's just
obviously and and particularly and
particularly if you want to have
children you know for women who are
mothers you know more a more stable
Society is just better obviously if you
want to be if you want to raise children
you know I shouldn't need to explain why
that is you know if everything's chaos
you know if and you've got small
children yeah this is this is obviously
a problem uh one of the interesting
things there that atomization of society
that you've said everybody treating
themselves as an individual that is
separate from the rest that owes nothing
to the rest of the world what you end up
with here is a bit of a tragedy of the
commons effect which is you're telling
me that I'm supposed to settle down in
order to contribute to societal
stability but if I let everybody else
settle down and I can continue to cycle
through my next thing until I find
somebody that is of the optimal Mr Darcy
shape size person that I'm looking for
that means that I get to benefit at the
cost of everybody else well unless
they've already got all the nice ones
and you're just left with the weirdos
and the porn addicts you know there's an
opportunity cost there as well I mean
you'd at the end of the day it's it's
your I don't mean your personally but
you know it's it's I do go for porn
addicts actually that's my that's my
primary my primary demographic well I
didn't like to ask Chris you know me
well um let men be men why should you
let men be men let men be well I mean my
the that's a very simple thesis
um you know if you it's all very well
telling women they should get married um
but that's not very it's you know you're
not going to get very far with that
unless there's somebody half decent to
marry
um and I think one of the problems with
you know there are there are a lot of
men who are really struggling
um and you know I'd probably don't need
to rehearse the metrics on that I'd say
you've had plenty of plenty of guests on
your show who've rehearsed the metrics
on that so I won't rehash them here but
there are a lot of men who are
struggling and that gets much more of
that because it's more obvious the
further you go down the social scale
um and it's although it's not it's it's
not a solution you know there is no
magic bullet solution to this but I
think one of the things that we have
women here really have to lead by
example on is
is letting men form one another if we
want good men then
we're like shouting at men is not going
to make men into better men because it's
just observationally clear to me that
women don't make good men men good men
make each other
I mean men
as men I'm really sort of hesitant to
generalize in this way but in or to kind
of
but it's
yeah
where it comes to learning how to behave
and learning how to be it's it's just
obvious to me that
men just don't listen to women you know
beyond a certain point you know it just
sounds it just sounds like
and they'll listen to their friends and
they'll listen to their dads if they
have dads and they'll listen to older
men who they respect you know who say
you know and if if they if somebody like
that says you know you should you know
if you want to be respected as a guy you
need to do the following things they'll
listen and the same if the exact same
message coming from their mum or their
girlfriend is just gonna sound like
and this is just observationally clear
to me
um and therefore if we want if we want
even the Fighting Chance of half decent
men who are worth marrying we probably
need to back the [__] off a bit and let
them let younger men form older men and
that means allowing more space for
single sex sociality for men
and it's also clear to me that we're
going to have you know the those of us
who are concerned about the invasion of
um gender neutral you know the the
incursion of gender neutral spaces in
even into places where that's obviously
absurd or dangerous or cruel you know
such as women's prisons then we're going
to get a lot more support from men if
we're not so hell-bent on Banning men
from socializing just amongst themselves
uh yes okay I see because you want to
have your spaces kept uh protected and
you want us to be on board with that
meanwhile saying that we can't have any
of our spaces left over
well I think the paradigmatic instance
of that is the scouts right yeah I mean
scouting went went co-ed you know some
decades ago and Girl Guides didn't until
until the gender woo came along and said
well no actually you know you you have
to have you have to have Girl Guides
with penises if they say they're if they
say the girls yeah yeah
um and and you know the girl guide you
know remember some sums a subset of girl
guiding has been outraged by this but of
course I mean it kind of happened to the
scouts some time ago
um you know that that went co-ed and I
don't I mean I can't really speak to
what was lost at that point because I'm
not a boy
um but I I wouldn't be surprised if
there were if if there were
opportunities for male socialization on
in specifically male terms that that
didn't happen as a consequence of that
and I think it's very difficult to prove
a link between the psychic the obvious
escalating levels of psychic distress
that men are experiencing and the fact
that there are now very limited
um all socially legitimate all male
spaces that aren't either produced as
far right or or under attack from you
know politically under attack from
um people who would prefer to see them
you know opened up in the interests of
egalitarianism but it's but the the
numbers are in that show you know men
are men are lonely
um in aggregate you know and
increasingly so and that's getting worse
and I think you know as a as a matter of
compassion and as a matter of justice
and also as a in it's in and also in
women's interests in the interests of
their being good men who've been formed
by other good men we
we should take a step back uh
fold this into that discussion around
how men shaped men and how women shape
men as well so from Roy Baumeister last
year when I spoke to him uh men will do
what women demand of them in order to
get laid women set the standards for sex
and Men meet them quote although this
may be considered an unflattering
characterization we have found no
evidence to contradict the basic General
principle that men will do whatever is
required in order to obtain sex and
perhaps not a great deal more one of us
characterized this in a previous work as
if women would stop sleeping with jerks
men would stop being jerks if in order
to obtain sex men must become pillars of
the community or lie or amass riches by
fair means or foul be romantic or funny
then many men will do precisely that if
men need to simply be in the right place
at the right time at 3am in the
nightclub then they will meet these
standards appropriately women are not at
fault for listlessness in men but
they're not totally unrelated to it
either how would you fold that into this
discussion
I mean it's it's a different way of
saying what I've just said you know to
I I suppose I could fold it into the
Joyce beninson quote you lobbed out
earlier as well in the sense that you
you could view the entire history of you
know technological innovations you know
a lot a lot of which were driven by
men's immense inventiveness you know as
a as a sincere effort to to make things
nicer for for everybody you know
including for women or you know Perhaps
Perhaps some of it was motivated by
wanting to impress women so perhaps some
of it was motivated by I mean I mean
yeah I mean sure there's a subset of
nerds who just like who just like
finding stuff up because they can
um but you know some of it is also
motivated by a desire for honor and also
a desire to want to get laid Yeah for
for men exactly
um and and if if in the process they've
put themselves out of a job and now
they're being told that and and in the
meantime they've invented a technology
which means that there's no longer any
sort of serious consequences to sex and
women are now all economically
independent and yeah together and
therefore all they really need to do is
to be in the right place at the right
time and there are no standards anymore
then
yeah I mean it's essentially saying it's
essentially saying the same thing I mean
how how we push back against that
um you know where where we start with
pushing back against that um I think
there's a there's a big picture you know
there's a big picture political
discussion which I've only touched on
very briefly in the book but at the
small scale I think it starts with um
with refusing the pill
now the the feminists fight back against
the pill
the feminist case for not being
pro-hormonal birth control
well I mean it's so it's a pro sex case
at the end of the day you know I mean I
I stopped taking the pill when I was
about 21. that's the last the last time
I took the contraceptive pill and I
stopped taking it because it made me fat
and sexless and insane
and I mean I'm old and wizard now so it
sort of seems a bit ridiculous even to
be talking about this and I'm 10 10
years married and just entirely just
spectacularly on the Shelf but I mean
you know I this is something I hear more
and more and more from young women who
are outraged having come off the pill in
their mid-20s having been on it for a
decade and having just been rooting they
put on this psychoactive medicine at the
age of 15 or whatever and they're just
like what the [__]
what did you do to me you know suddenly
their libido has come roaring back they
fancy a different set of people they
their mind you know they're no longer
depressed
um you know they they got so much more
energy and they did they just had a
total trans personality transplant
having having stopped taking this thing
that everyone told them was a completely
cost-free
um risk management
um
thing I told you about it was after you
finished the book that I pushed that uh
Dr Sarah Hill thing your way right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't think it was
it really I mean we you can start to uh
dig into the
genuine psychopharmacological
interactions of what's going on but it
doesn't change the fundamental
understanding like your n of one
experience
perfectly explains what what she says in
the book
um so I don't think that it really
needed to have that get folded in more
but if someone asked me uh a couple of
questions I've had recently like what is
something that you didn't believe this
time last year that you do now and what
is the biggest topic that is not being
discussed widely at the moment but will
be studied by historians in future and
for both of those it's stuff around
birth control hormone birth control
birth control yep yep and I mean I think
the the pro sex case you know the the
feminist prosex case against the pill
goes further than just
um it it messes with your libido and it
messes with who you're attracted to and
all of which has been you know I I
recommend to all of the viewers that if
you haven't you should watch Chris's
episode with Sarah Hill because it's
just fascinating and you Street her book
as well because it's fascinating
um but it but it's not just about the
way the way it changes the the basic
chemistry of of Attraction
um it's also about the fact that it
radically it radically changes how how
you how you form relationships and how
you how you approach sex and sexuality
um it you know but women more and more
women are complaining that they find
hookup culture degrading
um what is it what's the fundamental
enabling condition of hookup culture
you know if if you're if you're
repeatedly finding yourself in a
situation I'm probably going to get
canceled for saying this but I'm going
to say it anyway because I'm about to
get spectacularly canceled when the book
comes out so whatever
um
well I I read a lot of them me too
stories and a lot of the sort of you
know uncomfortable situations with
slightly dodgy men stories that got
written up in the context of
me too and that whole um that that whole
furore and it struck me that a lot of
them were the sort of awkward sexual
encounters where women ended up saying
yes kind of out of politeness and then
felt really gross afterwards because it
just felt too awkward to get out of the
situation having got having got
themselves into it
um and you know I don't want to make I
don't want to be heard here as making
any statements about what they should or
shouldn't have done in those situations
because I just feel for anybody who
wakes up the next day feeling icky in a
situation like that because it's because
I've done it plenty and it's just really
horrible
um it's painful and you feel squalid
afterwards
um but
what I will say is that if you're if if
you if you've taken birth control off
the table just you're very highly
motivated not to get into those
situations in the first place and if you
don't want to get into those situations
you should consider just setting the bar
higher for yourself by just not not
embracing birth control as something
which is a routine part of your your
approach to life
um you know you're not going to end up
hooking up with some guy who who
who you you turn up who you think is
disgusting when you wake up next to him
in the morning if you're just not
hooking up with anybody because you're
not going you're not getting that close
to anybody who you don't trust to look
after your interests as well which is
just you know obviously a very much
higher bar if there's a meaningful
material chance of you getting pregnant
you know you're just not going there at
all well I think so I asked a question
of
um Danica Patrick who is a female NASCAR
driver or your ex-female NASCAR driver
and I said um do you think that women
should have sex with men that they
wouldn't marry
and she it took quite a long time for
her to come to like formula an answer a
little while and she was like actually
yeah I think that's that's not a
particularly bad heuristic to use
um and also from our first conversation
I still remember you teaching me how the
introduction of the pill increased the
number of single mothers it did which is
it so radically changed the the absolute
the the the absolute number of casual
sexual encounters was so much higher
um as a consequence of the way it
changed it moved all of the goal posts
where it came to who was hooking up with
who that even even though the number of
the number of accidental pregnancies per
hookup was you know per total rate of
hookups was lower
um there's the the total rate of hookups
were so much higher that the absolute
number of accidental pregnancies went up
insane like so so so insane it's like
the biggest third fourth order effect
thing that you can't foresee
what's your final suggestion for uh how
we can abolish big romance
um
well well it's it's like we need to wait
we need to step the [__] back and and
let let them be we need to embrace
post-romantic marriage um and lean into
the fact that we're past progress and
then actually we need to rely on one
another and and be be looking seriously
for ways that we can increase solidarity
between the Sexes you know if we want if
we want to stand a chance of surviving
as a species
um we need we need to find ways of
increasing solidarity between the Sexes
and that means taking a step back from
endless optionality and it means you
know embracing marriage as an enabling
condition for for life in common
um and and the sort of radical loyalty
that you need even even when your
partner is annoying the [__] out of you
for for years at a time if necessary
um you know of you know obviously in the
in the absence of sort of serious
serious abuse or kind of major
psychological distress you know there
are some situations where yes
um families really are probably ought to
separate but in most cases you know
where it's just not ecstatic I think we
need to tilt the balance back so towards
a presumption in favor of of stability
presumption in favor of liquidity and
finally you know what what underwrites
all of this is is the feminist pushback
against the commodification of our own
bodies which has to start with how we
relate to our own fertility now I think
there's a there's the at the absolute
heart of this I think is uh is my my
I I I think I think we need to defy as
women this idea that we're just
defective males and you know and unless
we can unless we can flatten our
reproductive cycles and our reproductive
and our entire physiology so that it
mimics a male cycle and Physiology you
know more close or at least you know is
it it isn't obviously female in having
menstrual cycles and so on I I
I reject that as a basic premise and I
think it's I think it's profoundly
important you know feminist argument for
rejecting that as a basic premise and I
think it's a profoundly you know
fundamental to you know
pushing back against the
technologization the commodification of
everything that women have got to find a
way of saying no you know where we're
people but we're also female you know
and that's and that's fine too and you
know about how dare you suggest that I I
only get to access personhood if I just
if I'm willing to exert you know
biomedical Mastery over the things that
make me female you know being female
doesn't make me less of a person you
know how dare you suggest that and
furthermore how dare you suggest that I
should just offer up all of those things
there's just Commodities on the market
um yeah no I think we need to occupy
ourselves
who are you speaking to with this book
who would you like to read it most
um this is it's a really interesting
question actually I think they because
different different sections of it I
think are probably I've probably ended
up with a slightly different implied
readership depending on which part
um the hardest section I found to write
was the last one I mean what is to be
done is always much harder than you know
what's wrong
um and it I had I had four or five false
starts where I just wrote you know
thousands and thousands of words of not
bollocks but just you know unnecessary
stuff because I realized I was trying to
I was trying to please everybody and
then in the end I thought well no
actually I can't I can't please
everybody and who I who I who I ended up
writing the last section for was young
men and women probably more women than
men but young men and women who haven't
who haven't yet gone past the point of
no return
you know where you were young men and
women who still have a choice about how
they how they enter adult life and how
they form families or if they form
families
um where where they still have a choice
um but but particularly young women in
their 20s who've been who've been
looking around and thinking you know
there's something off about the message
of never-ending Freedom there's
something off about cyborg theocracy and
you know who haven't been able to put
their finger on exactly what it is and
why everything's why it just feels like
a massive um bait and switch and I
suppose you know I've I got to uh I got
to the amazingly well not the you know
they're reasonably reactionary opinions
I've arrived at by liberaling really as
hard as it's possible to liberal or you
know sincerely you know I've done my
best to Liberal as hard as possible and
I've arrived at a fairly reaction
replacing the course of that and I just
I just hope that there's a few people
younger than me who just maybe aren't
going to waste quite so much time
reaching escape velocity you know get
there a bit quicker and with slightly
fewer scars so
I think that this is part of a you know
the concurrent Trend that we're seeing
from a bunch of different angles whether
it's me talking about the mating crisis
whether it's Louise and the sort of
cultural side of things through the
sexual Revolution whether it's you
looking at the Historical then blending
into the technological otherwise Nina
looking at like the existential from
men's side of stuff like you know
everybody seems to be converging on this
demographics Stephen shows stuff uh in
terms of medical advances Dr Sarah Hill
stuff like everybody's pointing or a lot
of people that I find interesting are
pointing at the same thing and I think
that this is an important book to write
I'm really glad that you've got it done
uh why should people go if they want to
follow you if they want to keep up to
date with your work uh feminism against
progress will be linked in the show
notes below go and get that on Amazon
right now what else should they look at
uh I'm a regular columnist at unheard so
you can go and check me out there Mary
Arrington I tweet moving circles and I I
have a sub stack as well which you're
most welcome to subscribe to which is
reactionary feminist
Mary I really appreciate you thank you
thank you for having me it's been great
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
foreign